I I just started dating a guy who's nice
to me have you guys ever tried that oh I
used to date a guy who was really into
comic books like he loved all the
superhero movies every time a superhero
movie came out he'd make me go see it
with him and I'm not gonna do that
anymore
oh those movies are the same movie right
the titles all sound the same it's
always like green canteen versus crab
rangoon I wish I could just beam it into
every boyfriend's head when you make
your girlfriend see comic book movies
you're giving her two and a half hours
to think about who else she should be
dating yeah thank you I had a lot of
time to think yeah and and there are a
lot of things I wish I had said to that
last dude that I didn't I wish I had
been like hey buddy that time you told
me to stop texting during the Power
Rangers phase of Ultron I started
thinking about launching my own hummus
company and dating women
I know I don't speak for everybody on
this though I know there are women who
like superhero movies I've just never
met one of them are there any here what
are your lives like I just want to know
you must be drowning in dick I mean you
must have just a million boyfriends
thank you for your service yeah you know
I just had to draw a line in the sand
for myself it's no more three hour
movies about Happy Meal toys fighting on
a rock the guy I'm with now is great
he's he's nice and he's a giant which is
so fun it's great to be with a giant
when we walk around together it looks
like one of those viral videos that's
like unlikely animal friends you know
those ones it's like look at this
grizzly bear being nice to this raccoon
that's kind of our dynamic it's a pretty
fun hang I always wanted to date a giant
I just didn't think it was gonna happen
like I used to look at pictures of the
rock and I'd be like god I hope his type
is Jewish women who get tired easily
please let it be I just want to climb a
human mountain and you know now that I'm
with a giant I think everyone should
have the experience I think in a perfect
world everybody would get to spend one
night with the rock some of you seem
like you're not on board with this look
you don't have to have sex with them you
could just let him hold you like a baby
doesn't that sound nice being cradled by
the rock I mean I'm taking the sex
option I just wanted to give you guys an
out
I do think the rock could plow all of us
I know he could like I read this article
in a magazine is about his diet and
exercise routine and the rock eats 46
ounces of steamed Cod a day
it's like he's training to eat all her
[Applause]
I'm sure there are some guys here who
are like well he needs the protein like
pounds and pounds of cod that's a choice
baby The Rock's got a secret bucket list
item to the whole planet he's just gonna
sit up straight one day and be like
seems like a lot of ladies could use a
boost so download my app and I'll
squeeze you in between jumong geez I
don't want to - everybody's hopes and
dreams here but I found out yesterday
that the rock already has an app it's
called the rock clock and it wakes you
up at the same time as the rock and
that's it it's such a tease like you go
to download this thing and they're like
you want to wake up with the rock and
you're like yeah I do and then it goes
off at 3:00 in the morning and you're
alone and it's like time for morning god
thank you guys
[Applause]
hilarious really please come back we're
fantastic that's our girl
you